This work Bloodborne is japan Studio and
FromSoftware will be a completely new face for exclusive use. It's
like you expected up to 4 with the character prime minister.
But that kind of communication is also in
Bloodborne. Well, if you
say it's exciting now,
it's communication using a messenger car messenger character, or if it's
new,
there are old men and women.
I would like to provide something new in a place like communication using
This is a close map of the ruins that spreads out. This is the Holy Cup Dungeon. So
, the Holy Cup Men and Women This land price map
has characteristics that make
it look
like a figure depending on the viewer.  I think
that there are two aims for the generation men and women, and the first one is to provide something with the freshness of the strategy
.
Providing more and more dungeons to users always
means that users will continue to have targets for
capture, so
I want to influence
the sacredness of capture, and as another feature, it's
fresh.  I would like to post a new play of sharing the strategy to the user.I think that
this is the
same as that of Demon's Sole that there is always a new target for the strategy
.
I think that there is a lot of excitement around the release date by taking a game with a very high sense of value by taking a strategy in the wind
and achieving it.  It's a lot
of fun to
see, but it's still a release date. Diligence and preservation
.  Is
Really, in the Holy Grail dungeon, we can always provide new information to users, so we
can keep
pushing back without getting tired of it,
so if we say that, we will always share something like a fresh search.
We want to provide users with the play of being able to play
Bloodborne, as you would expect
, it is a work that you can of course enjoy the sense of accomplishment like Demon's Souls, and in this work
it expresses that death fight more.  By doing so,
I would like to provide users
with something like joy when it occurs or exceeds it.
I'm confident that I can expect it.
Also, like the
Holy Grail men and women, it's fun to share users
in various
ways.
Base porter play s